okay let me ask you about something
really fascinating that you are also
excited about which is longevity
anti-aging you have donated money to the
sense foundation so you have an interest
in this whole space of lifespan research
what's your vision here what do you hope
to see in
anti-aging and longevity research
i think i hope to see the concept of
wha of seeing your parents and
grandparents die just slowly disappear
from the public consciousness as an
experience that happens
over the course of half a century the
same way that getting lost in a city
slowly disappeared over the public
consciousness over the last 50 now that
we have smartphones
the the thing you have from nick bostrom
the essay
uh pinned in your twitter is argues that
essentially that you know death is
almost unethical like the fact that we
don't do something about this thing that
um
this in the essays is a dragon that
keeps
like murdering everybody around us
including our parents and grandparents
is uh
like the fact that we don't try to do
something aggressively about that dragon
is uh doesn't make any sense um
so you think this is a battle worth
fighting a
battle for immortality or at least
longevity
i'd say absolutely and i'd say it's a
battle where
we're really have started over the last
five years in particular to see
the first cracks of no humanity
starting to make things that look like
they'll turn into victories
do you uh do you think humans can
eventually live forever
and maybe as a side comment to that what
technology
do you think will enable that is a
genetic modification
is it cloning is it uploading your mind
define forever like are we talking a
thousand years a million
10 to the 14 10 to the 45
well let's start as i tweeted today
eventually everything
uh the universe will be filled with
supermassive black holes
so that that forever maybe like
backtracking to where we'll have we'll
have 10 the
16 years to figure it out yes
uh yeah maybe traveling between um
between the multiverse between the
different universes the multiverse
i mean but forever meaning like
you know uh millennia hmm um
i guess i definitely think that we can
get there um i definitely think that
it's the sort of thing that's
going to take an insanely huge amount of
work and i definitely think it's the
sort of thing where
you know once we figure out the first
crop of problems and
like people start living to 150 we'll
just realize that there's like 10 other
problems that kill you half as slowly
and we'll have to do more work
but you know the good news is that this
this is you know aubrey's longevity
escape velocity argument that
if you get everyone to lift 250 now then
you know you have half a century to fix
all those other problems as well uh so
yeah
i'm optimistic for that reason i think
um
it you definitely do not want to
underestimate
uh human ingenuity especially over the
long term but just to look at what
happens to computers between you know
the eniac in 1950 and where we are in
2020 right like that's
a span of 70 years um so like you know
both of us i think
with uh you know even just present day
technology and
i have i guess at least 70 more years to
left so just like imagine what kind of
sea change will happen in biomedicine
during that time and the other thing
that made me optimistic is that i
actually think
covet has been this kind of event that's
really
kind of pushed um biomedicine and
especially like activist approaches to
biomedicine really
into the public consciousness right like
it basically
it's put people into this mindset that
you know wait but like
you know it's not just like you know the
bits and tweets that are
going to save the world you know the bio
is actually like
super important and huge and
you know ultimately what's uh ending the
ending covet basically you know is
that the vaccines and the vaccines have
just been you know amazing
and if you can take that energy and
start and also like this uh
i think philosophical attitude that i've
noticed like i think
the way that i would describe the
philosophical attitude here
this is going more depth first is that i
think
the way that i kind of interpret part of
what i would call late 20th century
ideology is that there is this mentality
that
you know nature is good and disruptions
from nature
are bad and generally you want to
minimize disruptions from nature and
like this exists everywhere in the
political spectrum right so there's
nature as in literal nature
and my view is that like the right wing
version of that is markets as nature
right um markets as nature yeah like you
know they
the way that that like that kind of
philosophy talks about you know
markets and like the goal of not
interfering with them like you know it's
very it is very kind of like nature
styled
and then of course you know the the
conservative one which is like
traditional culture that existed before
the activists
started controlling everything as also
being a kind of nature
um but the 21st century attitude and
like really covet you know
has flipped a lot of minds because
with kovid what's happened is that well
no like it's not nature is not safe
right the default is that is like
you know untold and misery and suffering
and tens of millions of people dying
the only way out for us is through like
basically um human ingenuity
and that frame of mind is one that's
like much more friendly
to one the this other
change of minds that i want to see which
is like basically treating aging as an
engineering problem
right like the default is all 7.8
billion human beings that are currently
on this earth are going to die and
they're going to live
their last decade of life in a
debilitating pain and
the only way to stop that is human
ingenuity and you know we don't
we don't have that solution yet but you
know if we work hard we will
and more and more people on the biology
side computational biology
are basically converting the mess of the
the human biology into an engineering
problem
and once that conversion is happening
looking at the
the genetic code the proteins all those
kinds of things once that conversion
happens
you can now apply the tools that we know
how to solve engineering problems
to solving it that way and then there's
also the other version which is
you know why do we romanticize this meat
vehicle
that ultimately is just the thing that
carries the brain maybe we can more and
more convert ourselves into the digital
realm this is where like neural link
yeah have the brain computer interfaces
and then achieve
immortality in the space of information
in the digital space versus the biology
space
that stuff's interesting too i agree
again i think you know
we we have enough resources and we
should just try all the parallel tracks
you know it's great
that we have people just trying to make
our bodies work it's great that we have
people trying to
upload like or improve brain scanning
it's also great that we have just like
people improving cryonics so like we
could just like
you know go to sleep in the freezer and
um eventually
hopefully sometime in the future you
know healthy is going to be able to wake
up
um all of this uh um you know you know
anyone who
gets chronically frozen today will be
able to wake up but you know
that's all that that's a bad right
that's the last resort and then the
other interesting thing
about um the like extreme uploading
approach right is
um like we're excited about space
and one of the points that uh a lot of
science or like hard science fiction
types make is that you know if you want
to explore space that's a lot easier if
you're not a human
right like one example of this is that
you know
in the context of humans we're talking
about like oh we're gonna be able to go
to the moon oh we're going to be able to
go to mars
but there's this project called starshot
i believe right that's basically trying
to
send spacecraft to mini spacecrafts to
alpha centauri
and they literally believe that they're
going to be able to get spacecraft over
to alpha centauri like four light years
away by
like the 2060s no i mean by traveling
close to the speed of light yeah exactly
like
so base the way it works is you know you
have these light sails like you
basically take these a spacecraft and
you shine a laser at it
and the laser is insanely strong and
quickly accelerated at
100 g's for no i think it was 10 000 gs
um until it gets to 20 the speed of
light and then you know it goes on your
merry way
right so if you wants to be in
um like personally explore the alpha
centauri system
within like two centuries or once or one
century
then you know being a robot is like
by far the most practical way to do it
because there's no way that a human
being can survive 10 000 years
so it's it's definitely interesting long
term but at the same time
the there's definitely a lot of like
psychological hang-ups and a lot of like
deep philosophy that we'll just have to
grapple with
you